fin de la primera vuelta electoral en
costa rica que dejó como favorito al ex
presidente josé maría figueres la opción
del partido de liberación nacional
ni la pandemia fue capaz de doblegar el
espíritu cívico de nuestro pueblo uno
más la valentía y el amor a la patria
uno más la responsabilidad de sacar
adelante a nuestro país en segundo lugar
el economista rodrigo chávez logró
llevar a su partido progreso social
democrático a enfrentar el balotaje a
pesar de que los sondeos lo situaban en
cuarto lugar vamos a una segunda ronda
el partido nuevo el más joven de esta
campaña vamos a la segunda ronda
pero vamos a dejar atrás los rejuegos el
conflicto la confrontación estéril y les
ruego que nos aboquemos todos juntos a
pesar de la amplia oferta con 25
partidos el abstencionismo marcó un
récord de más del 40 por ciento debido a
la insatisfacción ya un gran índice de
indecisión entre los ciudadanos lo que
una espera que el país mejore pero en
vez de mejorarse empeora porque todos
prometen pero no hacen nada
después de que ninguno de los candidatos
alcanzará el 40 por ciento necesario
para ganar en la primera ronda los dos
aspirantes a la presidencia se
enfrentarán en una segunda vuelta el 3
de abril y quien finalmente gane tendrá
que enfrentar retos como la pobreza con
un índice del 26,2 por ciento en 2020 el
alto desempleo y la paralización de los
índices de desarrollo debido a la
pandemia acciones de largo plazo para
volver a ganarse la confianza del pueblo
costarricense